you
if you've ever fallen on hard times or
suffered a serious injury or even just
posted a sob story on Facebook odds are
you've had a friend or family member
reach out and say I'll pray for you
too many people prayer is a great
comfort both to the recipient and the
person doing the praying that's a
wonderful thing by itself but it also
raises the question is that all that
prayer does is it just a way to comfort
yourself and others the interesting
thing about prayer is that it's fairly
unique amongst spiritual topics in that
it can to an extent be measured let's
take a look at the Harvard prayer study
the largest prayer related experiment
yet conducted the goal was simple to
discern the effects of intercessory
prayer that is prayer on another
person's behalf on patients recovering
from coronary artery bypass graft
surgery the team involved with the
experiment known officially as the study
of the therapeutic effects of
intercessory prayer or step was composed
of investigators at six different
academic medical centers around the
country the team chose this particular
type of heart surgery because it's
fairly common among Americans with three
hundred and fifty thousand procedures a
year and because stressful surgeries
such as a bypass are prime reasons to
receive prayer the step team enrolled
one thousand eight hundred and two
patients from the six hospitals and
randomly assigned them into three
distinct groups the first group
consisting of six hundred and four
patients received prayers after being
informed that they may or may not be
prayed for the second group consisted of
five hundred ninety seven patients and
did not receive prayer after being
informed that they may or may not
receive it and the third group consisted
of 601 patients who received prayer
after being informed that they would
receive it care givers and auditors
comparing case reports to medical
records remained unaware of the
patient's group assignments throughout
the study the researchers also decided
to incorporate multiple denominations in
the study but ended up with only two
Catholic groups and one Protestant group
as the other denominations could not
make the time commitment required for
the multi-year study you may be thinking
hey wait everyone prays differently
won't that spoil the experiment that's a
good thought and the step team addressed
it they standardized the beginning of
the prayer and its duration so that all
the patients would receive roughly
equivalent prayers the step team
provided only the patient's first name
and the last initial to all the prayer
groups prayer began on the day of the
surgery and continued daily for two
weeks the results in the groups who were
informed
that they may or may not receive prayer
groups one and two complications
occurred in 52% of those who received it
versus 51% of those who did not
complications occurred in 59% of
patients who were told they would
receive prayer versus 52% who also
received prayer but were uncertain of
receiving it major complications and
30-day mortality rates were similar
across the three groups the results show
that prayer had no effect at all on the
outcome of the procedures if anything
the patients receiving prayer fared
slightly worse what does that mean is
prayer useless as a tool for healing
well yes and no there's a lot to be said
for emotional support and positive
thinking for many prayer is a powerful
way to show love and support now the
researchers conducting this test were
very careful to explain that the study
had no interest in proving or disproving
the existence of God they were simply
interested in prayer father Dean Merrick
one of the co-authors of the study said
our study was never intended to address
the existence of God or the presence or
absence of intelligent design in the
universe the study did not endeavor
either to compare the efficacy of one
prayer form over another or to assess
participants understanding of the nature
and purpose of prayer finally it was not
our objective to discover whether
prayers from one religious group work
better than prayers from another in
addition the step team did not ask
family and friends to withhold prayer
during the study nor did they expect the
patience to refrain from praying for
themselves this kind of test is
interesting because it takes a central
tenet of religion something which is
usually very hard to qualify and
quantify and measures its effects in an
organized way there are many people my
wife and friends included who say this
sort of test is worthless because you
can't put God in a test-tube and expect
him to act as our researchers want a
valid point perhaps but what should we
make of the results in my opinion if
you're inclined to pray continue to pray
it will raise your emotional state and
presumably that of the recipient as to
whether the words fall on empty space or
a divine creator that's a personal
matter for the people who are not
surprised by the results
don't go parading around bullying people
who are inclined to pray but maybe
gently suggest a personal visit to the
hospital or a handwritten letter in
addition to the prayer something
tangible to the recipient at the end of
the day prayer is what you make of it
just like any other form of positive
thinking use it or don't as you please
but respect to those with differing
beliefs either way
and do your best to provide comfort for
others however best suits you if you
enjoyed this video you can subscribe to
my channel by clicking here and you can
check out my previous video by clicking
here feel free to leave a like or
comment below and I'll do my very best
to respond to you thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you